[Applause]
thank you I know I know
lise it's a lot of shota's it big night
it's a big news day I know why you're
happy the mullah report finally came for
liberals this is like Christmas if it
was based on real events but
but wait nobody knows what's in the
report everybody had TV is giving an
opinion on this very important report
that they have not read I just saw a
graphic on MSNBC breaking speculation
what we do know for sure is that
individual one is in deep number two
[Applause]
but will it matter because no matter how
damning it is Trump at the last two
years has poisoned the well constantly
saying Muller is the crooked one right
and it's all been written by angry
Democrats and it's the deep state that's
what I used to do what I knew a bad
report card was coming I'd be like mom
keep in mind the teacher is an [ __ ]
who has it out for manse Trump has
tweeted over 170 times that this is a
witch-hunt and yet there's criminal
charges against 34 people 6 Trump
associates Manafort and Coen and Flynn
and stone and Papadopoulos and gates
that's a lot of witches and Trump
himself he's a whiny little witch you
know but hey it's spring this week can
we at least be happy about that
finally this winter is over and spring
break the time of year when drunk
entitled American kids head to Cabo and
Tijuana and the Mexicans chant build a
wall
[Applause]
but I love spring I mean the days are
longer and the flowers are blooming in
the president's mind is melting really
he is not colluding with reality I mean
this week began with the most voluminous
Twitter storm we've ever seen and then
when he ran out of living people to [ __ ]
with he started to some [ __ ] with a
cadaver John McCain all week long every
interview every rally standing on the
driveway just hurling insults at a man
who's been dead for seven months and
McCain's Widow Lindsey Graham says
nothing
Trump I swear to God
this week was blaming McCain for the
Russia investigation and for people not
having great health care not a fan he
keeps not a fan yet and tell me about it
today Trump asked his Russian hookers to
pee on McCain's grave I mean I'm just
testing your sensitivity but the other
stupid feud that the press covered this
week like it was the Cuban Missile
Crisis was Trump going after Kelly and
Conway's husband you know Kellyanne is
one of his key advisors and she's
married to a Republican a fellow
Republican but one with integrity
George Conway and George Conway is
always criticizing Trump in this week I
guess he went too far in Trump was a
he's a loser
he's a whack job this guy is a thug for
the husband from hell and and Kellyanne
comes out and defends Trump not her
husband she defends Trump like blondes
then we stick together
and then he did an interview with Fox
News this is where it gets scary not
just funny but scary talking about how
if the mullah report is bad the people
won't stand for it
whatever that means then he launches
into for the zillionth time his great
historic electoral victory he said they
came from the valleys they came from the
rivers they came from the cities they
came all from all over wait back up they
came from the rivers there's a trout
vote in Wisconsin and but my favorite
story the week trump ass-kisser and
justice obstruct ur Devin Nunez you know
Devin from he represents Fresno well
that's not accurate he represents Russia
he lives in Fresno
Devon Nunez is suing Twitter for 250
million dollars Twitter because they
heard his feeling because there was a
parity Twitter account you know you're
allowed to do parity in America I hope
still called Devon Nunez is cow because
he was a dairy farmer and an idiot he it
was not a good dairy firm he once tried
milking a bull all morning he said it
didn't give much milk but it sure was
creamy
you